OK.
A lot of questions are also coming in about
the debates.
Three debates have been agreed to in principle
between Joe Biden and Donald Trump.
Don't yet know when they will be, where they
will be.
Will there be an audience?
I don't have the details yet, but the question
I'm getting from a lot of people is essentially
how can we expect Biden to do in debates against
Trump?
A lot of right wingers are saying Trump, Biden,
dementia, Biden can't put together a sentence.
So let's put aside the hot takes about Biden
can't speak.
He's completely demented at this point.
I think that what we have to understand is,
first of all, historically, our expectations
about this debate is going to destroy this
candidate or that candidate.
That happens very rarely in high level politics
in the United States.
From my perspective, Donald Trump so thoroughly
embarrassed himself against Hillary Clinton
in the debates in 2016.
The debates did not move the needle particularly.
And Trump ended up winning, as we all know,
when the Democratic primary just a few months
ago feels like years ago.
But it was a few months ago when the Democratic
primary this year got down to Bernie versus
Biden.
You had the same Biden dementia people saying
as soon as Bernie gets a shot against Biden,
one on one, Bernie's going to Russia.
Biden is not going to be able to take it.
And Biden did fine in that debate.
Now, there are people who said after the fact,
well, it was because the moderators helped
Biden by making it all about Corona virus
or listen, people some people were convinced
there was no way Biden would even be able
to string together a sentence that was coherent.
Biden did fine and went on to win the primary
very, very handily.
So if you're expecting some black swan event
where we know every once in a while a debate
does change as a race drastically, you're
probably going to be disappointed.
I do concede, and I've been saying this for
a while, Joe Biden at 78, 77, is not the Joe
Biden that debated Paul Ryan, for example,
back in 2012.
So I believe Biden knows this.
I believe the people around Biden know it.
So I would expect Biden to train for a scenario
that favors him.
So knowing how to get under Trump's skin without
putting himself in situations for maybe the
type of rapid fire that would not be playing
to his strengths at this point in time, that
that's certainly, you know, maybe a case.
This has not, you know, on the on the Trump
side, people preparing him for the debate
are going to be probably in a futile manner,
trying to get him to think about the debates
in a way where he won't end up saying something
racist or xenophobic or discriminatory or,
you know, I want less testing because then
we find fewer cases or whatever.
So my vision is that the debates are likely
going to be underwhelming for anybody expecting
really the types of fireworks that you see
once in a blue moon that shake up a race.
Remember, according to the polls, Trump is
going to be coming into these debates playing
from behind.
But with the power of incumbency.
If Joe Biden can simply and this is not an
endorsement of any policy, if Joe Biden can
show up and present himself as the elder statesman
diplomat alongside this unhinged, wild, wacky
Trump doesn't have to change that many minds.
That will probably be good enough for Joe
Biden to maintain his lead.
What else did I want?
Oh, one other thing I wanted to mention.
There are people who are hoping that the debates
will be Joe Biden calling out Trump's belligerence
and Trump's insane comments and Trump's comments
about women and about black people and all
this different stuff.
It just doesn't really work that well.
Right.
I mean, we've seen that it hasn't worked well
as something to hurt Trump during the campaign
and during his presidency.
What has really hurt Trump recently has been
failure on corona virus, subsequent failure
on the economy, failure on his embarrassing
response to the protests against police brutality.
That's where Biden should focus, because we've
seen that the stuff that does just load off
or, you know, slide off of Trump is the stuff
about grab him by the you know what?
Where's my African-American tweeting the white
power video?
I don't think that there's really a winning
strategy there for Biden.
I think the strategy is look at the stuff
that's gone wrong.
Trump trying to gut Obamacare during a pandemic.
Right.
That's where the focus should be from a policy
standpoint for Joe Biden.